[Musik]
hey Leute eine ganz kurze kleine
vorabino hier bevor ihr lost Part 9
losgeht und zwar wollte ich euch nur
ganz kurz sagen dass mal wieder der Ton
von Minecraft nicht aufgenommen wurde
genauso wie bei den Hanger Games bzw bei
den Asia Games wde der Ton vom Spiel und
von noop auch nicht mit aufgenommen ich
weiß nicht warum ich habe vorher ein
Test gemacht mit dxtori ob es mich
aufnehmen kann und das und Minecraft das
war ein 5 Sekunden Test wo ich ein Block
abgebaut habe und dazu was gesagt habe
das hat alles funktioniert habe ich eine
halbe Stunde dann aufgenommen und hat
nicht funktioniert also ich werde
definitiv demnächst nicht mehr dxtori
verwenden deswegen ich weiß nicht ob ich
dazu noch ein Tutorial machen werde weil
keine Ahnung es funktioniert einfach
nicht oder ich frag mal ein paar andere
Leute die damit auch aufnehmen aber
erstmal sorry dass ihr kein Minecraft
Ton habt das war vor allem jetzt beim
Intro relativ komisch ähm wo ich mich so
erschrocken habe und ihr denkt h was war
denn da und zwar habe ich dort das
dieses Creeper gehört wo er dann
explodiert ist na ja auf jeden Fall
sorry dass ihr kein minecraftong Ton
hattet in Zukunft werdet ihr Ton haben
und dann sehen wir uns ja jetzt im Video
wieder viel
Spaß hallo hi ich bin auch noch da und
zwar bin ich lost ich bin so ein Projekt
das ist schon ca ein Monat nicht mehr
gekommen wegen Christmas craft und so
also ich bin Lua aber das ist das
Projekt lost und wir befinden uns nun
hier in meiner Welt und zwar in der
Version
1.6.6 da fragt euch nun bestimmt also
der aufmerksame Zuschauer des Projektes
hier wird sich nun fragen was 1.6.6 wie
kann das denn sein es war doch sonst
mein Version 1.5 ja ich weiß und zwar
habe ich mich dazu entschlossen habe ich
die Idee gefasst habe ich mein Kopf
gefasst hab mir gesagt Luca irgendwann
muss ja auch mal raufgehen 1.5.5 ist ja
blöd ich meine so ein Let's Play wenn
man das macht bestes Beispiel ist
einfach Gronk hat in der Alpha
angefangen und ist mittlerweile auch
schon in der neuesten Version in 1.4.6
weil man einfach mitgeht und ich habe
mir jetzt gedacht ich habe nun acht
Folgen lost aufgenommen denkt man sich
acht Folgen das ist recht wenig aber da
jede Folge eine dreiviertel Stunde lang
ist ja sind das 8 mal dreiviertel Stunde
ungefähr drei sagen wir mal vier Folgen
8 x 4 sind 32 folgen in einem normalen
Let's Play wären das und das ist schon
mal ganz geil also eigentlich sind wir
in der 32 Folge von also jetzt gerade
sind wir in der 33 Folge von Lost
äh aber eigentlich halt in der neunten
weil ich halt gesagt habe ich mache das
mit den stundenparts na ja jedenfalls
was ich euch sagen wollte bzw fragen
wollte
ähm soll ich in der Woche also ich werde
jetzt so alle zwei Wochen in der Version
hochgehen also alle zwei Folgen sage ich
mal oder jede Folge werde ich nun
hochgehen mit der Version das heißt
nächste Folge in der also ich werde
jetzt erstmal ein kleines Minütchen
quatschen da stelle ich mich mal einfach
hier hin da könnt ihr euch hier den
Sonnenuntergang oh scheiße die Sonne
geht
unter und zwar sind wir dann in der Z
also jetzt sind wir gerade in der
neunten wenn ich mich recht inne ich
glaube ja wir sind in der neunten that
means wir sind gerade in wion 1.6 das
heißt 1.7 wä dann in der Z 1.8 wä in der
11 1.9 wä in der
12 dann wiederum die
1.0 ich fin das so blöd wäre dann in der
13 die 1.
in der 14 die 1.2 in der 15 die 1.3 in
der 16 und die 1.4 in der wir uns
eigentlich gerade im Moment befinden in
der 16 oder irgendwie sowas ich weiß
nicht bestimmt habe ich mich e schon
1000 mal verzählt aber ist auch egal
jedenfalls sind wir dann so in
der 17 18 Folge sind wir dann so in der
aktuellsten Version weil ich denke wenn
wir in der Folge sind ist schon 1.5
Redstone Update draußen und dann sind
wir in der neuesten Version und dann
würde ich auch sagen ziehen wir hier weg
bzw ziehen mit der Zeit weg zwar werde
ich das noch zu Ende bauen nur mit der
Zeit verändert sich das natürlich hier
und zwar ich werde jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen so darüber quatschen was dieses
Projekt so allgemein hier angeht wie es
angekommen ist und so
weiter und zwar denke ich dass wir dann
schon hier weggezogen sind denn was ich
mal so testweise gemacht habe erstmal
alle die mich immer noch gefragt haben
sieht irgendwie komisch aus hier die
mich die ganze Zeit gefragt haben hey
Luca wo bleibt ein lost also während der
Weihnachtszeit während dezember und so
haben mich wirklich immens viele gefragt
wo denn lost bleibt da frage ich mich
echt wo bleibt euer gehirnum nein Spaß
ich liebe euch alle das wisst ihr
auch und zwar war losost einfach dort
ich TR mal ganz kurz ein Schluck
[Musik]
Moment lost war dort wo ihr nicht wart
nein
Spaß und zwar war das so warte mal ist
das schon das Update wo man hier drauf
rumlaufen kann ne
schade und zwar habe ich ja gesagt dass
ich
zu Weihnachtszeit kein lost und kein
tropy craft machen wollte tropy craft
habe ich allgemein schon mal gesagt in
dem Video was mit tropy craft los ist
von daher braucht ihr da gar nicht in
den Kommentaren
Fragen und zwar wollte ich lost einfach
nicht währe der Weihnachtszeit machen
weil ich finde Weihnachtszeit wollte ich
nur Christmas craft machen und habe ich
ja dann auch hingekriegt mehr oder
minder und na ja Bo ich liebe das
einfach los hat man 60 Minuten wo man
einfach nur quatschen kann das ist
richtig geil so
und zwar habe ich das da halt pausiert
deswegen geht das nun weiter und zwar
ist ja Weihnachten auch schon wieder
eine Woche zwei Wochen her deswegen habe
ich mir
gedacht irgendwie hast du jetzt schon
eine längere Zeit keine l mehr gemacht
Luca ne mein Kopf gefasst hab mir
gedacht jo nimmst mal wieder eine Folge
auf habe mir dann allerdings gedacht als
ich die Folge aufgenommen
habe nimmst mal lieber die Kopie und
packst sie wieder rein die Folge war
derbe scheiße weil ich so derbe schlecht
gelaunt war
und keine Ahnung also ich habe halt
Facharbeit kurz vorher noch also nicht
geschrieben sondern kurz vorher das noch
vorbereitet komm mal kurz hier
mit und da ist man schon fertig wenn man
so eine 16 Seiten Dings Bums yay das
funktioniert schon mit dem Drücken hier
ja
egal man an schon so ein bisschen
schlecht gelaunt wenn man das die ganze
Zeit vorbereiten musste aber egal
jedenfalls war es dann der Fall dass ich
schlecht gelaunt war dann die Folge
gelöscht hab dann in der Kopie wollte
ich gerade wieder eine Folge aufnehmen
ich habe eine Kopie und nein das habe
ich nicht von gron geklaut weil jeder
let play hat Kopien von seiner Welt
a ich liebe dich ne spaß was laber ich
eigentlich wieder für ein Bullshit ne
egal und zwar habe ich oh habe ich noch
Glas drin und
zw was wollte ich sagen ich weiß es
nicht
mehr ach ja wir wollten ja alles voll
mit Glas machen irgendwie
ne werde ich denke ich anders lösen bzw
an den Rändern ich weiß nicht ja an den
Rändern wollte ich das so machen na ja
stimmt dann haben wir es doch nein
verdammt egal habe ich dann wiederum
gelöscht und habe mir dann allerdings
gesagt irgendwie habe ich viel mehr Bock
auf so let's play in der neuesten
Version weil ich da dann auch verzaubern
kann dort kann
ich dort gibt es alle möglichen anderen
Mobs okay nicht deutlich andere aber es
gibt halt Enderman und
so und allgemein gibt es dort viel mehr
Blöcke das heißt viel mehr Möglichkeiten
viel bessere generierte viel besser
generierte Biome wie z.B dungel gibt
auch und sowas alles hat ich halt so
voll Sehnsucht nach der neuesten Version
sage ich mal weil da habe ich halt
vorher lost aufgenommen dann hatte ich
so richtig Bock so in der neuesten
Version was aufzunehmen habe dann eine
neue Welt generiert und habe ungelogen
vier Stunden am Stück
aufgenommen und wollte das dann in
einzelparts hochladen es wären dann ich
habe gar keine Axt das wären dann
hier oh Gott das wären 16 Parts gewesen
allein am Stück aufgenommen von dem
neuen Let's Play dann habe ich mir
gedacht komm das lösch du ich wollte
nicht schon wieder was Neues anfangen
weil ja weil ist so ist einfach so nein
weil ihr habt das ihr wisst dass ich oft
Ideen abbreche einfach so wenn ich
keinen Bock mehr habe und ich weiß daran
sollte ich arbeiten deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht komm mach du lost weiter und
dann habe ich auch eine Nachricht
bekommen von einer Person bei Facebook
eines Abends wo ein Kumpel von mir da
war sind mir meine Nachrichten einfach
so durchgegangen ihr wisst glaube ich
dass die meisten meiner Freunde wissen
dass ich das mit concrafter hier mache
und dass sie das auch schätzen und dass
wir da manchmal auch ein paar Fragen
sarkastisch beantworten wenn uns
langweilig ist na ja
jedenfalls war es dann halt dazu
gekommen dass mir eine Person
geschrieben hat hey Luca ich will weil
ich habe bei Facebook gepostet was wollt
ihr lieber lost jeden jedes Wochenende
40 Minuten oder ein Let's Play die Woche
3 Parts 15 Minuten kommt das gleiche bei
raus da waren die meisten natürlich für
das normale Let's Play aber das die
Umfrage ich danach wieder gelöscht oder
sie ist immer noch da ich weiß es nicht
jedenfalls habe ich mich nicht daran
gehalten und nachdem ich diese Nachricht
gelesen habe wo dann eine Person meinte
hey Luca ich habe dich echt abonniert
weil wegen lost und lost ist so ein
Projekt das macht gar kein anderer Let's
Player weltweit niemand spielt in der
alten Version zumindest habe ich das
nirgendswo gesehen als ich sag das
gerade mal so ein bisschen aus der Sicht
von dieser Person die mir die Nachricht
halt geschrieben hat
m und sie findet das halt total cool
dass ich das mache und finde es blöd
dass ich das eventuell aufhören lasse
wenn ich diese Umfrage da befolge und
sie möchte doch dass ich das weitermache
und so weiter und so fort vielleicht
habe ich mir dabei erstmal nicht viel
gedacht do dann danach als ich dann die
Dateien gesehen habe und hochladen
wollte den ersten Part vom neuen Let's
Play ich mir gedacht nee lässt es lässt
es sein und zwar ganz einfach weil ich w
ich wieder was Neues anfangen und ich
bin noch irgendwie froh dass ich dieses
Let's Player habe wo ich so ein paar
alte Sachen habe und mich dann quasi
alleine hocharbeiten kann in den wir
Version wann immer ich will und wann
immer ich wieder zurückgehen kann ist
natürlich beim normalen Let's Play auch
so aber dort verlangen verlangen dann
natürlich die Zuschauer dass man in der
neuesten Version
spielt allerdings Tatsache ist auf jeden
Fall und das ist jetzt der Fakt der
bleibt
und de facto ist es auch gerade so dass
ich diese Version weiterspielen werde
also jetzt nicht weiterspielen ich werde
wie schon gesagt jede Folge das ändern
dass ich dann hochgehe in der Version
bzw irgendwann ne runtergehen ist blöd
aber ich werde halt immer weiter
hochgehen sass ich dann irgendwann in
der neuesten Version drin bin in Folge
17 oder so
und sagen wir mal ich bin in Folge 20 in
der neuesten Version dann hätten wir 20
Folgen mit 45 Minuten das heißt 20 x 4
das werden schon 80 Folgen Let's Play
für euch 80 normale Let's Play Folgen
bei irgendeinem anderen normalen Let's
Player von der Länge her und ich finde
einfach das ist schon eine Menge und
dann kann man schon mal so ein Projekt
meine wir steigern uns sehr langsam und
ich hoffe einfach das ist für euch okay
also ich sag das gerade alles so als
wäre das jetzt total schlimm als würde
ich mit aufhören also ich sag's mal so
ich werde es in Zukunft so machen dass
ich alle ein bis zwei Wochen alle ein
bis zwei Folgen sage ich mal die Version
hochschrauben werde weil ich einfach in
Zukunft auch enchanten möchte und mir
neue Möglichkeiten erschließen möchte
und so weiter und das geht einfach nicht
wenn man in dieser alten Version ist wo
man diese paar Einstellungen hier nur
hat
und na ja oh ich bin auf Peaceful fällt
mir gerade auf na ja ich hoffe ihr könnt
das einfach verstehen dass ich in
Zukunft einfach hier wegziehen will dass
ich ich sag mal ich glaube ich mache
noch so ein Hintereingang dass ich mein
eigenes Ding machen möchte und ich hoffe
einfach dass ihr damit auch
einverstanden seid oder soll ich so
hinter ich meine wo mache ich denn sonst
den Eingang ja der Eingang wird hier
reingepackt so B da dass ich mein
eigenes Ding machen will ich hoffe ihr
seid damit
einverstanden und ma da jetzt nicht rum
weil ich könnte jetzt sagen ja das ist
mein let Play und ich mache was ich will
aber so bin ich nicht das wisst ihr auch
und ich lasse euch damit
entscheiden wo immer ich nur eben kann
und na ja deswegen ich denke wir werden
nachher eh noch das Glas ein bisschen
weg maachchen aber ich mach jetzt
erstmal dahin damit wir hier erstmal die
die nächtliche Behausung einbinden
können
ähm Glas ist weg ich habe noch ein Stck
Glas ist weg ich habe noch ein Stck y
Glas glas gläer
gläer na ja jedenfalls das wollte ich
euch nun erstmal sagen dass ich dort in
Zukunft auf jeden Fall in Version
hochgehen werde und das so mit jeder auf
seine Rechnung kommt also wer alte
version will kann sich diese Folgen
angucken W neue Version will kann dann
einfach da fehlt noch Zaun äh kann dann
einfach habe ich nicht noch ganz viele
Zäune ja du da ähm kann dann einfach ja
abwarten sage ich mal abwarten und Tee
trinken übrigens warum habe ich das hier
noch mal frei
[Musik]
gemacht oder habe ich das ach ja ich
wollte diesen Zaun auch noch damit
drunter fließen lassen fällt mir gerade
auf und da musste ich das ja so
wegmachen
stimmt weil man konnte ja noch nicht so
durch den Zaun durch na ja
ähm
das heißt wir sind dann in der nächsten
Folge schon in der Version 1.7 ich weiß
zwar nie was da drin vorkommen wird
allerdings denke ich dass in Version 1.8
werden glaube ich schon neue Biome
kommen ne 1.9 war das
1.9 kommen zfbiome und sowas alles dazu
und wie schon gesagt ich möchte dann am
liebsten einfach hier wegziehen bzw mir
die wichtigsten Sachen mitnehmen und
dann woanders hinziehen woanders mir was
Neues aufbauen oder halt wirklich
komplett von vorne anfangen und zwar
ganz einfach aus dem Grund weil ich
kenne das von einem alten Let's Play was
ich ganz ganz ganz ganz früher mal hatte
auf einem ganz ganz alten Kanal conquero
LP hieß das das kenne noch einige von
euch dort war auch eine versionsänderung
und
dann war das der Fall
dass scheiß Deutsch dort war dann der
Fall dass mein strandbiom bzw das hier
was hier so cool grün war war dann auf
einmal so eine komische Farbe so eine
komische graulila Farbe vom Gras her
weil das in so einem sumpfbiom lag und
dann war das hier direkt am Strand und
das ist alles total beschissen aus
einfach
nur deswegen hatte ich
jetzt nicht so Bock das irgendwie noch
weiter zumachchen weil das All total
scheiße aussah deswegen dachte ich dass
wir wenn sich die Biome hier so ändern
dass wir dann das ganz viel Erde wir
brauch ganz viel da ist
Erde deswegen hatte ich mir gedacht dass
wir dann einfach wegziehen und eventuell
woanders hinlaufen und von dort einfach
neu
starten und also keine neue weltanfang
sondern einfach neu starten und das
nennen wir dann einfach weiter die Folge
das heißt wenn wir in Folge weiß nicht
wenn in Folge 15 sich die ganzen Sachen
hier Verändern von wegen Biom und so
dann ziehen wir dann fangen wir dann
folge 17 von ein komplett anderen
Position an irgendwo hier auf der Map
und na ja dann werden wir irgendwann
schon wieder zurückfinden können ich
meine ich weiß ja dann wo ich
hingelaufen bin ich lauf dann na egal
ich LAF dann immer in irgendeine
Richtung hin und dann fange wir von dort
halt wieder von vorne an wo es dann
schön aussieht und dann werden wir dann
auch mit Texture Pack spielen weil wenn
ich hier mit dem Texture Pack Spiele
dann ist das alles total blöd und na ja
ich hatte ja damals auch mal ein Texture
Pack hier drin Sache war nur dass
eigentlich kein s Sache war nur
dass viele meinten dass ich mit dem
default ture Pack weiterpielen soll weil
das einfach zu dieser alten Verion passt
das habe ich mir einfach zu Herzen
genommen habe jetzt gedacht ja komm
spielst mit defult weiter ich weiß do
gerade gar nicht was wir hier noch so
alles bauen wollen ach ja wir müssen
erstm das Haus und Erde brauchen wir
auch noch oh Gott Kön ich den Erde
abbauen a das habe ich letztte mal schon
gefragt mache ich jetzt einfach
hierlich relativ egal wo das abgebaut
wird macht der keinen großen Unterschied
ob ich das jetzt hier abbaue oder da
ganz hinten und irgendwie ist mir der
Sound bisschen zu ich habe schon die
Befürchtung dass wir dass es nachher
alles viel zu laut ist was ich aufnehme
bzw meine Stimme einfach viel zu leise
ist und ich da ich jetzt nun nicht mehr
mit A C aufnehme also meine Stimme
ist es nur der Fall
death obwohl ich könnte mal theoretisch
die Kombination Audacity dxtori
verwenden also ich bin zur Zeit echt
ungeheim am rumspielen mit Shadern
dextori und so weiter und na ja
jedenfalls re ich das jetzt erstmal Erde
ich weiß es gerade gar nicht wir haben e
schon viel zu
viel jedenfalls wo war ich den gerade am
Reden ach ja kann man bei DX2 nicht
einstellen wie laut PC sein soll wie
laut die eigene Stimme sein soll
deswegen habe ich gerade immens Angst
dass ich das nacher die komplette
Aufnahme wieder für ein Arsch ist hatte
ich letztens schon mal habe ich ganz
ganz lange Hunger Games aufgenommen
ungefähr 30 Minuten eine
Folge und nachher hat der dxory nicht
meine Stimme aufgenommen ich hatte
einfach so war so gefrust ich habe das
direkt gelöscht bei den Asia Games
wiederum die ihr heute boah jetzt muss
ich komplett Plan weil ich das alles im
Voraus aufnehme die ihr heute morgen um
13 Uhr gesehen habt oder heute Mittag
ich glaube das muss hinkommen da war es
auch so da habe ich das danach vertont
weil ich da einfach da war es mir
relativ
egal e ja cool ich kann kann ich doch
nicht schade so
komm na ja jedenfalls ist es alles ein
bisschen blöd mit dxtori deswegen werde
ich wahrscheinlich wieder auf dxtori und
frs bzw DX Audacity bzw Fraps und
Audacity zurückkommen so never change
running system sage ich dann
nur das sieht jetzt hier alles ein
bisschen abgekarpert aus so machen wir
so na wenn da Gras drüber Wechsel und
hier soll das Gras mal endlich schneller
wachsen sehr schrecklich hier Set erstm
so ein paar Fackel hin damit hier ein
paar Mops eventuell spawnen werden boah
die Erde sieht so grau aus ne das ist so
traurig so also hier wollte ich dann den
Eingang zur Dings machen da brauche ich
aber auf jeden Fall auch noch
Cobblestone weil der Eingang soll ja
nicht so groß
sein
so ich ma den glaube ich drei
groß so dann mache ich da Glas
[Musik]
hin und da muss nun irgendwie noch eine
Tür rein oder so oder ma ich das lass
ich ich lass das so mein Gott Krit euch
das n so auf das läuft
das
koppels war mal soll ich das jetzt
[Musik]
so ja ich glaube ich mach das so
m dann packe ich da eine Tür rein ich
brauche allgemein zwei Türen habe ich
die schon mal irgendwann gecraft warte
das war da war gerade eine Tür das H war
falsch Tür kommen sie
her so jetzt haben wir hier unser
kleines gebäudchen D MS wir durch ich
wollte hier noch eine pressure plate
hinlegen wie macht man die noch mal
warte das ist so klug von mir dass
diesen crafting table direkt hinter den
ganzen Öfen platziert hab ne es war
einfach so ein richtiges Meisterwerk ach
ja das war die Zeit wo es noch egal war
womit man crafting table abgebaut
hat
so und dann schließt sich von alle und
wenn ich reingehe dann schließt sie sich
auch sehr gut
ich wollte hier oben so eine so ein Raum
eigentlich
reinmachen wo ich Kisten hinstelle nur
ich frage mich gerade wie ich da hochkme
weil ich will hier keine Leiter rein ich
glaube ich mache einfach so so eine
Treppe ach
W W die habe ich
schon dann bau ich mal einfach so ein
paar
treäppchen vier müssten eigentlich
reichen ich Dach sch wird wieder nach
also wenn wir doch theoretisch eine
zweite Etage drauf bauen schon gesagt
ich möchte das hier vier
hochbalten kommt das hier hin oder B ich
das hier drei
hoch ne ich mach das vier hoch so da
kommt dann die Etage hin au oh da gab's
no die schönen Minecraft Sound
stimmt heißt ach ich da hier so eine
Raumtrennung ist fange ich die
treppefach hier an neh ich mir
[Musik]
Erde so 2 3
4 so dann oh das war be schon recht weit
warte mal wenn ich doch in dieser
Version die Treppen abbaue nee dann ich
will es gar nicht testen dann sind die
eh weg nee warte die müssen zwei weiter
nach da bitte komm zurück als Treppe nee
kommt ein Block ja toll ja ich glaube
die gingen sogar hier am schnellsten mit
dem Schwert kaputt das war so die
Version wo so alles komplett
durcheinander war so wartet mal da das
dann so
aussieht hier müsste die letzte Treppe
[Musik]
hin
so so gut jetzt muss ich mir natürlich
wieder neue Treppen machen das war alles
total unnötig was ich gerade gebaut habe
aber es ist soll uns erstmal relativ
egal
sein so
Hop nee
[Musik]
ne woll ich doch verkackierern e schon
wieder falsch ich bin auch so klug dass
ich das nie irgendwie teste oder so ne
e man
Manometer
so jetzt
aber so da sind unsere vier Treppen wir
brauchen allerdings noch
mehr ach ja ich weiß doch hier muss die
Treppen noch so so da war es egal wie
man die hingesetzt hat das wurden
einfach immer richtige Treppen
so so jetzt haben wir den Weg das heißt
kann das hier wegmachen und aus Holz
ersetz meine Spitzhacke Schaufel ist
kaputt und da gab's noch
keinen Sound der dann irgendwas gemacht
hat als das kaputt gegangen ist so und
da wollte ich jetzt Holz
hinpacken B aber schon viel
Holz viel schon wenn man doch jetzt hier
hoch geht ja dann mache ich hier so ein
Raum hin wo ich dann die Kisten einfach
irgendwo
hinstelle die Sache ist natürlich jetzt
auch wieder dass wir das Holz hier nicht
so krum machen können deswegen müssen
wir das Holz hier einfach so drauf
lassen deswegen müssen wir allgemein
noch eine
Menge Holzfällen gehen na
gut wir haben ja Zeit wie oft habe ich
das schon gesagt hey wir haben doch gar
keine Zeit was redest du denn da das
Video ist do gleich schon vorbei so
warte kommt man da jetzt noch drunterher
wenn ich das so
[Musik]
mache J dann passt doch mit meiner
fetten Schnauze hier so warte ich Lager
jetzt noch ein paar
Sachen und ich würde sagen dann haben
wir es auch schon eigentlich wieder für
die Folk oder also wir haben so viel
Sand ne und das einfach nur ach ja das
funktioniert jetzt auch und das einfach
nur wegen die ist
voll K hatten wir den ganzen Sand drin
stimmt na egal die ist gleich auch schon
voll die Kiste hier daraus können wir
uns Brote
machen 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3
ach nee da kommt man Brote noch nicht
ach Gott jetzt haben wir wieder so viele
Brote so Glas brauch ich auch nicht mehr
Strings auch nicht
das sortiere ich mal so ein bisschen
Eisen habe ich gar nichts doch da habe
ich noch ein Eisen das kann ich mit
Schaufel machen yay
[Musik]
die er schön könnte ich erstm so ein
bisschen wegschieben hier geh ab in die
stille Ecke so warte hier platzi ich
noch
Fackel Angst dass trotzdem was SPT na
egal sollte eigentlich
funktionieren warte du brutelst erstmal
noch hin fertig wir brauchen
Stick hatten wir glaube ich ja
höhlenound wir wissen dass du auch noch
da bist Sticks hatten wir glaube ich gar
nichts mehr hier ist auch noch so ein
Helm drin den könn ich auch noch
aufsetzen
so wieder ein bisschen Platz
gemacht ja Sticks dafür brauchen wir
auch dafür brauchen wir ja
auch
Holz ich weiß do gar nicht wie lange ich
hier aufnehme ja ich w Zukunft wieder
mit a city machen weil ich dort wirklich
mal auf de rechten Bildschirm sehe wie
lange ich gerade aufnehme das ist schon
ein entscheidender
Vorteil so du gehst auf das war
noch nicht reif hey du hast was geertet
das war noch gar nicht reif
diabo hey guck mal die Kisten sind von
ne hier habe ich ein nur falsch
platziert wieso packe ich das nicht
einfach hierm rein und die beiden Sachen
packe ich dann einfach hier rein so die
Kohle kommt damit rein habe ich auch
noch Kohle
nö wieso habe ich eigentlich so viel
Öfen die brauche ich alle gar nicht ich
pack mal so ein paar hier weg oh es wird
Nacht ja ist leer du kommst auch noch
weg ich werde do gleich wieder ein Stopp
machen e ich nehme schon wieder so lange
auf ne ich weiß ich habe das ungefähr so
im Gefühl wie viel ich immer so quatsche
ach Gott jetzt müssen wir so lange
laufen wieder da haben wir alles schon
eingerichtet hier noch nicht auch sehr
klug Glas habe ich jetzt auch nichts mit
immer wenn ich hierherlufe höre ich
Zombies und das Gras da hinten ist auch
noch kein Stücken weiter gewachsen ich
glaube ich bleib einfach mal so eine
Weile hier stehen und beobachte das Gras
dabei wie es wächst und dann haben wir
ich meine das ist ja eine Version da
kann ich auch noch nicht cheaten das
heißt ich stell mich dann einfach hier
hin und ich hoffe es kommt kein Monster
es wird herprozentig Monster komm ich
sag's ja weil ich die Tür nicht
zugemacht habe
egal ich Brau ein Block Brau
Block so na was geht na komm geh weg
einmal ein mal die Kuh
so schön
schlafen guten Morgen so meine lieben
Freunde dann würde ich sagen das war's
ich pack D me wieder rein das war's für
diese Folge lost für die neunte Folge
ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr einen
Daumen Hoch geben würdet wenn es euch
gefallen hat
wenn es euch halt nicht gefallen hat
dann Daumen runter aber ich denke wenn
es euch nicht gefallen
hat wenn es euch nicht gefallen se hat
wenn es euch nicht gefallen hat denke
ich mal dass ihr nicht mehr hier seid
weil sonst wä es irgendwie relativ
unklug wir müssen uns in der nächsten
Folge auf jeden Fall begeben auf jeden
Fall hinkriegen Baum zu
fällen dadurch kriegen wir dann Sticks
und dadurch ich töte nun einfach mal
alle Kühe jedenfall da sind eine Spinne
dich töte ich auch noch geh weg so
danke und durch die Sticks können wir
uns dann zB die eisenschaufel machen
oder
auch zwei Creeper in meinem KF Alter ihr
wollt mich doch verarschen wenn ihr da
explodiert
[Musik]
ne boah double Alter auf einmal so ein
Ding neben mir die wollen mich do echt h
alle verarschen darauf ich erstmal ein
Brot alter
Schwede nicht dass alle Schweden alt
sind aber das hier war ein sehr se alter
Schwede junge da sind zwei Creeper in
dem Ding drin und dann auf einmal noch
einer hinter mir ja das hißt schon was
meine Damen hören meine Damen Herren
meine dam und hören hört hört concrafter
kann kein Deutsch oh Gott ich habe das
Gefühl das Gras wächst wieder rückwärts
na ja das ich wollte gerade sagen das
war's für diese Folge und ach ja ich
wollte mich ja zum Ende hab ich mir so
überlegt mit Axt vom baumstell N Folge
weiß dass ich ein Baum fällen wollte so
Freunde das war ein Schlag von mir in
die Hände normal und ja wie schon gesagt
wenn ihr gefallen Daumen hoch nächste
Folge sind wir 1.7 und dann sehen wir
uns beim nächsten Mal tschüss